a lot of people writing to me saying
David you've got a comment on the bonus
show about Apple eliminating the
headphone jack from their devices and i
do want to comment about that and i want
to tell you also i do not have any apple
products uh I'm not one of these anti
apple people per se we've always edited
on adobe premiere on pc systems my
laptop is a Windows computer uh I have
an android phone so I'm just not in the
whole Apple world but I still find this
very very interesting because it is
similar to when uh you stopped seeing
the HSE's when you stopped seeing uh CD
players on many many laptops when you
stopped seeing what else I'm sure there
are many many more examples of this so
first of all you are still going to have
three options for using headphones or
earbuds to listen through apple products
one is wireless right and sooner or
later everything is going to be wireless
power uh power charging is going to be
Wireless we're already starting to see
developments there we already have
wireless internet connections file
transfers between networks computers can
already to some extent happen wirelessly
and that will get faster and faster and
faster we have a wireless bluetooth
headphones which already are very very
popular at sales of those are growing
more quickly than sales of wired
headphones for the first time ever so
wirelessly is going to be one element of
this now of course apple also has a
solution as they always do to every
change that they make apple is going to
start including new earbuds with the
iphone that plug into the charging Jack
so this was a confusion people said oh
no more headphone jack so I can't use
wired headphones anymore know you can
it's just that they're now going to plug
into the charging Jack rather than a
separate headphone outlet there are
other companies that are already making
headphones that's up plug into what's
called the Lightning jack on Android
phones you can plug them into the USB
see Jack which also is the equivalent
charging Jack on Android phones and then
lastly if you have a pair of regular
headphones with a three and a half inch
but audio plug that you really really
like you're going to be able to get a
little adapter which will work to go
from your 3.5 inch plug to the apple
lightning jack or from your 3.5 inch
plug to the USBC jack on your android
phones some of them will have splitters
so that you could charge your phone and
plug in headphones simultaneously who
knows how long those will be around but
it will be for a while I I have to be
really upfront I find this interesting
and I find this sort of natural that
we're going in this direction I don't
think that this is that big of a deal
and a lot of the anger around this was
Apple is making obsolete what just about
everybody has and there's sort of two
sides that story on the one hand 3.5
inch audio plugs are actually very very
antiquated but because nobody has made
the decision to say hey you know what
we're ready to move past that we don't
need that on our devices we've continued
using very very old essentially
switchboard like technology it is not a
digital connection and it's sort of
natural that we would start to to get
beyond that and yes there is going to be
a period where people are going to need
an adapter to get to the backwards
compatibility and and and be able to use
that but this is like with everything
else we've seen this change many times
uh we've seen changes to the plugs for
electricity and and many items that gelt
get electricity from the wall we've seen
Bay's over periods we are going to see a
phase over period as we move away from
cars that use fossil fuels during which
there will be exemptions there will be
kids to make your non electric car sort
of electric we're going to see all these
things things tech technologies are
grandfathered in etcetera etcetera I am
truly truly not concerned with it I do
find it interesting that Apple has just
said hey we are doing this period